here's what i understand if you don't
care about animation quality in your
hentai no
then why do you not read doujins i don't
want to [ __ ] turn a page
i draw the line having to move one of my
limbs beyond what i'm already doing
you're already moving one i don't have
to go
oh next page i'm a fast reader as well
joey
okay what about try on your [ __ ]
phone cause you have your
the other hand what did you flick yeah
okay you know what gage you know what
like
because this is awful right you know
when you've watched like you know you've
had to watch it on your phone you had to
make dude yeah right
i [ __ ] hate it when you get a message
from someone when you've like it's like
you've got it and it's like it's like
joey
messages what are you up to i'm like for
[ __ ]
start this progress bar now [ __ ] help
it puts me off so that's why i
chromecast
i'm just gonna message you every hour
now just hoping that i'll catch you
that's why that's why i chromecast it to
my tv so i don't have to know
you don't get a big [ __ ] notification
from like duolingo being you [ __ ] why
are you masturbating wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait you
are you watch it on like your [ __ ]
wife you're watching
my tv in your living room no not living
your bedroom bedroom
i want to be in bed dude i wanna you
know come on man i wanna be cozy
because i okay i can't do it sitting up
like i don't know why
i can't do it like i've only done it
sitting up basically really oh yeah
do you do it lying down yeah dude that's
a [ __ ] mess man
get tissues what the [ __ ] mainly
i can do in any position really like
standing up sitting down like
he's very happy no i mean i like
obviously you know it's it's
i don't know it's gonna be comfortable i
wanna be optimal comfortable i get that
i get that
but some but it's hard to like [ __ ]
like look
at the same type of like pillows pillows
man
like i'm in hospital like i'm in a
hospital bed just sit up there oh dude
you have like the optimal [ __ ] gamer
set up to [ __ ] jerking off
but you can't just like use your second
hand to hold a phone
no you're
you know big screen you need like a
[ __ ] google next page
google next page
okay if i made if i made like a [ __ ]
powerpoint presentation for you
if i like converted dojinskis to
powerpoint presentations for you which
you can chromecast and you can be like
next page next playstation would you
would you be able to do that
would you do that ah maybe yeah yeah
probably actually i think i could
actually so wait it's not even the
matter of the fact that it's like
it's on paper and it has words that you
have to do it's just the fact that
you're too lazy to turn a [ __ ] page
yes that's the problem that's what gets
you soft yes
it's i don't like holding my phone
because my i text on my phone all the
time i don't like looking at the pawn on
my phone
i'm gonna be honest with you i don't i'm
gonna make a gamer setup for you just
for jacking off man
it would be like optimized right it's
the same reason why like if you've ever
been like
you know i'm sure it's happened at some
point right maybe a relationship and
they've offered to send you a nude
picture
right right i don't look at that [ __ ] on
my phone like what do you look at it on
then
i just don't look at it at all i'm like
i i it's [ __ ] what is that there's a
story going on here why are you saying
this [ __ ] wait what what's the reason i
i you know when someone sends a nude or
something you know you've been in a
relationship right i'm sure yeah maybe
you sent me you know
i i can't wait to still image on my
phone why should you stare at him
you want them to send a [ __ ] synopsis
along with the photo no no i don't want
anything don't send anything i'll do it
myself
i'll find i have methods i have the
hentai websites which i can chromecast
to my bedroom
well yeah in that case like the video is
always better but like
what i'm saying is that you know if if
even if it's
a dojin right if you if you play on like
a powerpoint right let's say it changes
page every five seconds right that's
fine i can i can do i can deal with that
so if i made one for you would you do it
yeah i'll do it i could do it so you
basically just need like a hands-free
version of the jinchi and you'll be
pretty much yeah why don't you like
i wonder if we could like [ __ ]
connect it to like the alexa like alexa
next page
maybe i can wear a htc vive while i'm
doing it
the vr pawn was made for people like no
no no no no no because like i
would say like one of the big advantages
of the jinshi is that you can go your
own [ __ ] pace
because you know you have you you have
certain scenes in an anime right when
you're just like man this [ __ ] scene
is taking too long as
as you've already said yeah well you
just don't want it you don't want to get
involved and [ __ ] be buffering it
like every time there's an interesting
scene which is normally like why you
know like you just kind of guess you're
like all right i reckon it'll be
it'll be the scene here and it'll get
good in about 30 seconds or a minute
right
so i'll just skip to there and i'll be
like go ahead and if it's really taking
the piss and it's going on for a good
five minutes i'm like oh
[ __ ] come on you're having a laugh yeah
and then then i'll go up and i'll
reluctantly get out my phone and be like
all right
i'm still going still going and we're
done let's see that's what i like about
dogen is that like
as you said you can go at your own pace
right so if there's like a scene that's
like really hot yeah like you can take
your time you can take your time you can
look at the all the [ __ ] finest
details
you know so he just puts it on the like
[ __ ] mice did i [ __ ] frame that
[ __ ] i'm just like damn that that's
that's a piece of art right there i'm
just lazy i think that's what's the
problem
yeah we figured i mean you you say
you're lazy but you go into
like you go into like extra steps
in order to [ __ ] yeah in order to
chromecast it and
be like i don't know how can i describe
it i have to use like an expressvpn
thank you shout out when they sponsor us
and i use that and then i have to like
get a separate app to chromecast videos
that can't be chromecast
so it's a bigger why would you bother i
just because i don't want to watch it on
my phone i really hate watching stuff on
my phone like that i don't know
it really is like it bothers me like so
much you say you're lazy but this is
like the opposite of lazy this is
putting in x
this this is putting in extra steps just
to enjoy some [ __ ]
no i i get it but like it's like
it's like to me it's like the winnie the
pooh meme where gaunt is the normal
winnie the pooh and i'm the winnie the
pooh that's like yes
yes chromecast like picture
you know watch watch on pc monitor watch
on chromecast
and hands-free experience free
chromecast so i gotta say like
you got [ __ ] balls so chrome to like
press the chromecast button
that's just that's just like the the
sign of someone who's obviously living
alone yeah because i imagine like
no i used to do it when i had roommates
as well really yeah and we had two men's
living on the edge
because i i was confident right because
there's like a five second buffer for
chromecast
and i knew there were five seconds like
i was like i knew if it wasn't buffering
immediately i'm like
abort mission chrome casting hentai
listen it's the future
which okay if if you were at your
parents house would you dare press that
chromecast
if it was in my room 100 because because
my my house in my
like my parents house have too many
chromecast that's like that's like
it's a [ __ ] danger wank at that point
man you're playing you're playing a
dangerous game
what are they all called tv one like
all it takes is one miss click man all
it takes is one slip of the thumb it's
like defusing a bomb
you cut the wrong wire you're just
[ __ ] right okay listen let's say it
happened right
i i'm fine i can go and be like mom come
on you know you know
come on mom what am i supposed to do
what if your mom just comes up being
like queen bee really
that's what i'm more disappointed about
she's like owen watches pink pineapple
yeah
my favorite child watches pink pineapple
accidentally chromecast mother blows
breasts
i didn't raise you for [ __ ] 23 years
just so you can watch
milky listen